hey guys today I'm going to do a video
on non-dairy sources of calcium a lot of
people have allergies to the protein in
milk a lot of people have lactose
intolerance so they have a lot of
digestive issues so they want an
alternative one of the challenges you
might run into is that even no almonds
and spinach are high in calcium they're
also high in oxalates which can irritate
your your joints and even cause kidney
stones if you're susceptible to them so
I'm gonna take these off the list okay
and just talk about the ones that are
fairly safe canned sardines with the
bones okay
that's a good source of calcium salmon
is a good source of calcium and also
other fish bok choy all right now kale
now kale has some oxlips but it's low on
the list and if you're doing lemon juice
that should that's those sit rates
should prevent any any issue with kidney
stones
broccoli would be a good source of
calcium now also if you take vitamin D
or you're getting Sun that will increase
the availability of calcium now lastly I
just want to mention one situation with
people that might have this
consideration they have an allergy or
they're lactose intolerant when in fact
they're just sensitive to a protein and
casein called any one okay Casey so what
you might want to experiment with is to
do the a two type casein which is in
goat cheese or sheep cheese and see if
you have any reaction to that and that
way you can get some calcium from dairy
but without the inflammatory response
alright thanks for watching so you know
my viewpoint on this topic I want to
know your viewpoint what do you think
about this video go ahead and comment
down below